welcome to our new and Wolfram language
12 webinar series today is the second
session in a four part series that
covers significant areas of new and
expanded functionality in Mathematica
and the Wolfram language my name is
Jaime Peterson and I'm the technical
programs manager for Wolfram you a free
and open learning hub that features
interactive courses video classes and
webinars like this one thank you for
joining us today today's topics are all
about the extended capabilities of the
Wolfram knowledge base the world's
largest and broadest repository of
computable knowledge which powers
Wolfram Alpha and the Wolfram language
joining us are Tony Schindler developer
of the entity framework Andrew Stein
occurr lead developer with our
scientific content group Alan Joyce
director of content development and
Keiko Hirayama developer for biology and
medical content we'll be taking a deeper
look at the new entity query
functionality and also at food and
nutrition data cultural and historical
entities and computable knowledge in
biology and medicine let's get started
with a poll question that will help us
understand who's here in the audience
with us this poll question asks about
your experience with the Wolfram
knowledge base you might be familiar
with the knowledge base from your use of
Wolfram Alpha or from your use of
Mathematica or the Wolfram language or
maybe both the poll should be showing up
on your screen so go ahead and check
whichever answers or answer applies to
your situation okay I think we're
probably ready to share those results if
you're curious to see who's here with us
today as you can see lots of Wolfram
language Mathematica users which we're
very happy to see and then also a good
number of people who have used either
the free version or the pro features
which are subscription-based of Wolfram
Alpha so thank you everyone for being
here we really appreciate that
we think we will have something to
benefit everybody the next poll I want
to ask is about the version of the
Wolfram language you're using so for
those of you using the Wolfram language
we want to work yuria Stu know if you're
using version 12 already or an older
version in the his version 12
announcement blog Stephen Wolfram wrote
that the curated knowledge base in the
Wolfram language is vast and continually
growing with every version of the
Wolfram language were progressively
tightening its integration into the core
of the language so if you're using an
older version of Mathematica you may not
be aware of how conveniently this data
can be accessed in version 12 and we're
excited to show you some of that
functionality today and Wow
looks like a good majority are already
using version 12 which is terrific you
have everything at your fingertips then
ready to explore the things you've seen
today I'll share those results with you
in just a second there we go
so yeah 61% at 12 and then a good number
at 11 and then some using older versions
or have not used the Wolfram language or
Mathematica yet so that's really great
to know thank you
so I think we're ready to get started
with our presentations I'm going to pass
the microphone to Tony Schindler now and
we're ready to get started thank you hi
I'm Tony I'm working on the entity
framework as well as semantic
technologies think graph query language
spark I'm going to give a quick
introduction to entity queries new
entity called functionality so here's
the outline so for someone who might
need a refresher in entities or has
never heard of them
a quick introduction to entities
properties and classes and after that we
are going to see some query primitives
queries means filtering of entities or
sorting them allocating and combining
those are primitives because you can
combine those primitives to form more
complicated queries and then I'm going
to mention some in the backend that you
can use with those entity queries
as well as sparkle how that relates to
entities so to start let's seen entity
here's the natural language interface of
the Wolfram language you can bring it up
for instance by hitting ctrl equal and
then you can type anything that comes to
your mind in in this case the zebra when
you hit Enter it gives you one of
potentially many interpretations now if
you don't give enough context you might
get multiple interpretations as in this
case no but I'm happy with the
interpretation
I want it to have an entity that
represents zebra and then what can we do
with an entity
well we can look up properties for
instance the maximum speed and an image
of the zebra new is the ability to
specify computed properties using an
entity function that means you can use
an arbitrary computation in any place
where you could also use a property now
in this case we are getting again the
maximum speed an image and the color
negated image and we see a tsipras still
looks like a super after that operation
except for the eyes neck this looks like
a simple operation but later we'll see
how useful that is the next concept
after entities and properties are
classes of entities here's an example
class the class of odd planets if I
evaluate it you see that nothing
happened
other than formatting that's good
because an entity class is just there to
represent the collection of entities
yeah if you want to know what the
members are you have reapply entity
listed you might be wondering what order
those entities are in yeah they seem to
have an order but the order in
entity classes as we have known them
since earlier versions than L don't have
a specified order so it could be in any
order but you'll see later how we can or
what we can do about it you can also ask
for properties of classes and what does
that actually mean that means give me
that property for all members of that
class in this case I want the image for
all planets in this case we don't see
yet which entity tows image correspond
to because the default result form is a
list but we can change it to an
association to see that for instance
this one is Earth now as I mentioned
before entity classes don't have an
order defined but just a new construct
sorted entity class we can order or
define that the order of the entities in
that class followed that of a certain
property now for that I can sort all
planets by the distance from Sun and now
I can be sure that the entities that I
got here are ordered by the distance
from Sun but now comes the power of the
new entity function I can't sort only by
predefined properties but by an
arbitrary computation for instance I can
sort the planets by the ratio the
distance from Sun Tomas yeah
so you see the entities came back in a
different order the next operation is
filtering now we start with a class or a
type which basically means all entities
from that class and then we applied
predicates to all of those entities to
figure out which entities should be in
that class in this case we are finding
polyhedra with more than 150 faces and
again as we stay
the classes before those things don't
evaluate and that's a feature of all of
those new query function our query
functions so you might want to build up
complicated queries from simple ones so
you don't have to worry about them
evaluating before you're done writing
your query only once you do something
this those classes yeah
is the query actually evaluated so in
this case I am asking for the image for
all of the entities in that class in
that moment that query is executed and
the commit retreated so image so those
seem to be the polyhedra that have more
than 150 fists now comes the first
complicated or more complicated example
this may be the second most complicated
example application what does it mean
let's start simple we are starting this
planetary moves and we want to group all
of the moons by the center they are
orbiting and then for each of the groups
the group certified by the center we
want to count the moons and we want to
determine the total mass and we can
achieve that by saying here the cluster
disturb is optionally a crew by property
or compute a yeah this is optional
because sometimes you want to count or
total everything here in this case you
want to group by center and then we
define for instance the moon count by
getting an actual product is the moon
and what do we get back a list of empty
lists for the list has the right length
so that's the count of the moles and we
can also total the mass of the moons in
each group and now we can apply entity
list to this new aggregated entity class
and you can see that this is really a
new kind of entity first of all in the
formatting in this little symbol which
somehow seems to indicate application
but also the tooltip you see that the
first argument of entity
it's not a string anymore like in
previous versions but a query that
defines the type also the canonical name
which is the second argument is now an
expression namely the value of that
grouping predicate yeah then what are
the properties where you have three
properties first of all the thing that
you grouped by because it's a constant
across each group so you have to orbit
Center and then the two properties that
you define the moon count and the total
mass yeah and let's take one of those
new entities let's say the group of
moons orbiting Mars you know and ask for
a data set we could have chosen
Association but just to show you a
different result for snow and the orbit
Center is as expected Mars yeah and it
has two moons and well dead mass and now
comes the most complicated of all of the
very primitives yeah it's combined
entity class but there are many ways in
which you might think of combining no
but let's say you have a list of two
elements and another list of three
elements you might think that you get
five elements by combining them you
should place one of the data but that's
not the combination that you're talking
you're talking about combining in the
sense of a relational database join so
to explain that let's start with Pokemon
because Pokemon are a tool for
explaining complicated stuff No
so we'll get for this Tentacruel the
image just for your illustration but
also the type and what do you see you
can see that a Pokemon in general can be
of multiple types yeah and now let's
look at another property to attack and
now you might be wondering what is the
average attack for a Pokemon of a given
track if the type were a singular that
means every Pokemon were just of a
single type the answer would be easy
because you could just group by their
type and then yeah
average the attack but in this case we
have to do something more complicated
because the type is a list now so we
want to form all Pokemon and type
combinations and then after that group
by type and compute the mean now and we
do this with a combined entity class
which is a join and the join is
basically an outer product which just
means form all the combinations of
Pokemon and Pokemon type and filter
those combinations by this predicate and
to see this new entity you see there's
again a new type of entity it has a
different symbol yet again another sum
and this seems to be indicating
combination and the type is again a new
kind of type it's not a string but it's
the query that you started with and the
canonical name that you can see as the
second argument of entity is composed of
the canonical names from those entities
and those entities and you can look at
the properties and you can see that it
has properties for both types some from
pokemon and Stanford Pokemon type yeah
and now we can compute the mean attack
by aggregating over the class that we
started here so now we see the power of
the new query functionality because we
are able to nest arbitrarily those query
primitives in every place where I can
use a class you can use a query
primitive which is itself a class so you
can reuse so now we are grouping by
Pokemon type and computing the mean and
here we see the result let's get that
numeric those are not sorted yet but he
comes sorted if you like but there's a
wait it can be fine assorted entity
class sort by attack and get the same
result yeah so we have just nested the
combined entity class with an aggregated
empty class and an associate entity
class and you can continue doing it now
about back ends so the war for knowledge
base contains many built-in types and
you can apply those entity queries to
any of those types you can build your
own entity store register it and then
apply those credit images to those
entities or given combinations of your
entities and building entities or if you
have a relational database you can make
an entity store out of it and registered
and apply those very common tips to it
and actually those query committees were
invented to support very in relational
databases and now a quick look at
Sparkle Sparkle is the graphic every
language of the Semantic Web normally
you would very RDF that means resource
description framework data using sparkle
but we are trying to apply and this is
very experimental spark occurs to
entities and if you know Sparkle already
it consists of triple patterns and in
this case I'm trying to look for triples
that have as a subject that means the
thing that we're describing carbon then
as a predicate image and this is so
variable that means when we apply this
query to the domain element now we get
all possible bindings for the image
variable in this case we got one image
this would have been easy if you G if
you just do it like that no but now if
you want to do the reverse query it
would have been a little bit more
difficult using sparkle it's still
simple doing a reverse curve it just
means right it robot that has a variable
subject position then the property and
then the value so that means you're one
trying
find all the physical systems having
four degrees of freedom and we see for
instance the inverse distance potential
in 4d which you could use for instance
to model four-dimensional hydrogen atoms
and the last slide here we're doing we
doing the Pokemon example the query
looks much simpler because when we apply
Sparkle to entities we automatically
flatten lists valued properties now that
means you don't have to worry about the
coins and we're retrieving using that
query the attack and the type of each
Pokemon then we are defining an
aggregate which looks pretty similar to
the allocated entity class the argument
structure is the same except that in
sparkle everything as an operator then
you compose both queries and apply to
the entity type Pokemon and you get the
same result just a little bit different
structure which is typical for Parker so
that concludes the quick introduction
and now I'm passing to Andrew who's
going to show some examples and
applications of disclosure and
technology so I'm going to be talking a
little bit about the entity query
applications that you can do with some
of this a lot of new stuff the Tony
showed my let's all quickly show off
some of the examples that we've prepared
all along we'll look at a few examples
because there's there's a long moment we
don't have a ton of time to go through
too many things so I'll try and just
cover a few of the more interesting and
perhaps more quickly understandable ones
as well so the first thing I look at is
I'm filtering continental plates by
their geological period where we'll use
filtered entity class for that and I
also work on the food and nutrition
content stuff so I'll show them about
that with nutrient ratios with you know
a couple of these things that only Tony
showed and lastly I'll quickly look at
some award winning restaurants and then
the data project that one of my
co-workers Ahmad was interested in where
we used an energy store to be able to
use this stuff to to do some neat things
so to dive right in
ah ah the first thing we'll do is use
filtered entity class to write some
Wolfram language code to be able to
select geological periods who's who
satisfy the condition that the time
range is greater than the last 550
million years along with that it's not
too hard to go find those which we can
use with entity lists which is a second
here you can see that these aren't the
geological periods that actually satisfy
that criteria so this is an easy way to
use Wolfram language code to be able to
query for this sort of information we
can also write another entity function
here that grabs the continental plates
from each entity and then we grab the
keys which are dates we sort them in
order and we make columns that have the
common name the date and some
Geographics so as a quick example all
showing you what the result looks like
for the Jurassic period for example so
this is just the first and last frames
that are produced for each one we can
kind of see what they look like so it
says what a period it is and then the
years on which they are shown and with
that it's not too hard to be able to
make a nice little animation here just
by calling entity value on those periods
with the entity class and then using the
plate outline entity function what I
have there then we just want the lists
out and drop it into list animate and
then we get this nice little animation
of the movement of the geological plates
over the last five hundred fifty million
years so it's kind of a neat example
there moving forward we can go a little
further and I'll talk a little about
food now I saw some questions earlier
about the control equals their face or
the natural language input I've sort of
done this here where I can just evaluate
this real fast and so basically if if
you if you want to see how that's done
normally you would use control and the
equals key to be able to pull up a new
cell like this and you can do safe
refried beans as an example hit enter
and then it will come up with law and
entity you can look at
here she cooked a little button then you
can actually evaluate that and have that
stored there
so I think I also saw a question where
someone was asking how these can be
stored in variables and just like this
you can just drop the drop a symbol here
hit equals and then it's stored in there
and if we do refried beans now we get
that so this structure might look a
little different on more than some of
the other things Tony showed this is an
implicit identity which means in the
second argument there is a list of rules
that's that specifies how it is filtered
down and it represents sort of water
food on so this is using the food type
property to narrow it down to beans and
those that have been prepared as refried
and they don't have any extra foods
added to them so we can use extended
entity class on this to be able to add a
new property called the protein to fat
ratio where we take the protein content
and the fat content we divide them and
we'll use quiet to silence any Methow
messages that might happen like for
example it's the fat content to 0 ma it
might you know divide by 0 and that
could be problematic
moving forward we can take that example
there and use filtered entity class to
only keep the longer versions of that
stuff so any any entities where the
protein to fat ratio is a longer so
we'll use one cube for that then we can
also use sorted entity class to be able
to find the 10 nutrient out of the 10
Allah refried beans whose protein to fat
ratio is greatest and put them in a
descending order which we can do there
and then finally we can pull that out
with energy value or this shorthand
energy value syntax to be able to see a
lot the results there which I'll show
here where you can see some high end you
know it's about 12 times as much protein
whereas on the the end of this 10 it's
more like 7 so that's kind of
interesting to see that way so that's a
quick example that way there with some
food things I'll quickly go through this
example next which is involving
award-winning restaurants this is a
more complicated example so I won't be
able to show it all but it does touch a
lot of our technology on for example my
coworker was really interested in
gathering data on a word winning
restaurant since he has a background in
culinary science and so he wanted to
gather this data himself analyze it and
then see if we could find some
interesting things with it so the first
thing he needed was a dative in which
the Wolford data drop allows you to add
data to continually collecting them on
VIN and so you can use the create
database function to build one and you
can use data bit add to have things to
it and then he used a one form of the
Wolford cloud to be able to gather that
information he just built a simple web
form to be able to enter the information
on his own using form function and cloud
deploy and then on ma he used an entity
store from that they didn't gathered our
use functions like data set to be able
to create the MD stir lastly from that
entity store Tom he was able to register
it and then do some interesting things
there there's actually a marketing page
if you get the notebook there's a link
to the actual page itself that goes into
more detail on some of those other parts
but really only going to focus on the
last part which is about querying it the
first thing we need is to download the
entity store which I have hosted in the
cloud and once we have that we can
register the entity store which returns
a list of the types that were added to
entity values on my type system and from
there if you take one of these like the
award-winning restaurant type you can
actually see the properties and those
sorts of things that are available and
so he gathered a lot of information on
cuisines cookbooks awards and those
sorts of things in order to kind of
analyze and group them then from there
it's not too hard to write queries to be
able to find restaurants that match
certain criteria so like for example
this is an implicit entity class where
we look at award-winning restaurants
whose awards must contain one Michelin
star and then we can use sorted entity
class to be able to sort them by opening
date and then only grab the top five for
the first five rather and then we can
use entity value to pull
the dates and their cuisines which you
can see here on vary quite a bit and the
dates go back even as far as the
eighteen hundreds even which is
interesting going a step further we can
actually look at a different subset by
looking at again using the awards so
restaurants that have one Michelin star
and let's say let's grab those that
whose closing gate is currently
operating so that they're not actually
closed they're just currently operating
and then we can write another entity
function here we'll call it is inside
NYC to determine if a location is within
New York City and so we can say well if
it's a diem position let's use geo a
thank you to be able to test if it's
within the entity of New York City so we
can test this on on one of our entities
here and we can see that this one is
indeed inside New York City with that
information we can take that and we can
use filtered entity class to use on that
function we wrote to pull out the
locations of the restaurants that match
that criteria and once we do that we can
plot it out which I'll show here so you
can kind of see that it's not too hard
to use jiva list plot to be able to show
that and as one more piece of
information to kind of take it a little
bit further we also used find shortest
tour and travel directions to be able to
find optimal real world of paths through
all of the restaurants in New York City
either by driving or walking I won't
throw the code here because it's a
little involved but but I guess I'll
show the result here which is rather
interesting how the routes for driving
and walking differ as an example in
order to get all get through all of them
and with that I think that kind of wraps
up the entity query side of things and
so I think now I will jump up jump over
to my food presentation right over here
and so I'm also I as I mentioned earlier
I work on the food and nutrition content
and so I will be talking about this a
little more here so to give you a brief
outline of what I'm talking about hot
today I'll give you a quick overview of
food nutrition in the Wolfram language
on how its organized on that sort of
thing and I won't be able to show all of
examples that we have our page on the
webpage but I will be able to go through
a few of them on particular I'll be
looking at price lookup codes or appeal
view codes as they're sometimes called
and look at some brand name comparisons
and labeling terms and how to compare
those and I'll also be talking about
some ingredient substitutions and food
groups but more or less we have lots of
information on packaged foods nutrition
being able to look at Dietary Guidelines
and that sort of thing as well as lying
to cooking times and the language in
turn a tional food thesaurus but
unfortunately I only have enough time to
look at a couple of these things forward
here so to give you a brief idea of what
is in the how the food and nutrition
information is structured in the Wolfram
language there are three approximate
types that you really need to know food
of course is the first one which Allah
as you might imagine is the most common
and most most detailed actually as well
we have about a hundred fifty thousand
entities and we have over 600 properties
and as you can see from the sample
entities these are very detailed they
have locked they have very long names
and they have lots of things to qualify
what they need and that sort of stuff
too additionally food types is a another
type to to consider where we have quite
a few less there's only about a thousand
eight hundred of them in comparison to
the foods but there are a lot less Allah
detailed so for example rather than a
specific variety of Apple we only have
just apple rather than chicken prepared
a certain way it's just chicken and so
this allows us to more pleasantly
compare and sift through the foods that
we have one thing to point out is
another type are what I'm going to call
classification types for foods and these
can be found with the categorical
property values property and this shows
the actual breakdown of how these foods
are classified in our system so we have
a system of about 10,000 entities and
about 50 different categories to be able
to write foods down from how they're
packaged on their processed or alone
part of their food set
been added to them so moving forward
with some of that information that's
kind of the rough idea how how the
system is organized moving forward let's
look at the first example here which is
about PLU codes or price lookup codes
these are codes that are used or widen
like grocery stores to classify and
label produce among other things and so
we have now entities on those so these
are just simple four-digit numbers as
you can see here where there's a lot of
information about them including what
category they belong to or they fruits
vegetable and so on as well as what
commodity which is sort of like a food
type in a sense of bananas asparagus
apples and then there's also information
on specific varieties that correspond
each on long peeling you code
additionally there's also an other
information including like sizes whether
its large or small and that sort of
information as well and the nice thing
about these if you've been to a grocery
store and you've seen the fruit or other
other produce typically has barcodes
that look kind of like this lemon and
the nice thing is is that the built-in
function barcode recognized can actually
read that without much trouble and in
fact here I'm just doing a quick string
take operation to pull off only the
portion of the the stuff that actually
has the PLU code on in barcodes so but
you can see that the nerves pull down on
from there now you'll have to once once
you have the number itself you can put
that in as an entity and here I'll just
use data set to be able to see a couple
properties for that and you can see that
it does belong to lemons it's for large
lemons and the size for a large lemon is
defined to have a diameter of at least
65 millimeters and we can also see that
it's aligned to the lemon food type as
well as a few foods in our database for
example and if you don't believe me
because that one that last image just
had among the numbers on it our code
recognized isn't using the barcode
itself not the numbers and so you can
see here that this one is for 1/1 which
is for a banana for example and we can
produce more information out of that
like to be able to pull out that it is a
banana using the food
property and we can also produce
nutrition labels from that information
as what all so that kind of wraps it up
for PLU codes and I'll move forward to
food brand names so here we have one one
of the types that we have for
classifying foods is brand names
so here I've just grabbed a bunch of
different brand names that might be
recognizable and here I can use the
foods property to be able to find the
foods for them so for example if I look
at a particular brand I can see on mom
these are some example foods and we can
take a look at how many are in each one
here so it's a handful of foods for each
one as you can see and another nice
thing about our data is that we also
have images for a lot of packaged food
so for example here this is just some
example images that we have for these
brands here as you can see there's a lot
of planogram type images that we get for
all of these things so with those images
after we've lined them for each brand we
can also find the ingredients for them
so for example for this particular food
these are the particular on packaged
food ingredients that we actually have
for it
and so we can take a look at all of
those by aligning them to the brands and
we can see that if we look at how many
are in each brand it looks like Gamla
French's has a lot more than say a
coca-cola for example it looks like and
from that information we can use
features based plot to see kinda how
they all relate in a 2d way and so a lot
mom this uses machine learning and
neural networks to be able to determine
where they are and here I've just used
label to be able to show the image for
them and so you can kind of see that
sodas are somewhat grouped together
pastas are kind of grouped together and
so heart these two candy parts for
example and mustards vary a little bit
depending on what kind of mustard it is
it seems they're kind of in the middle
somewhat together as well just kind of a
neat way to look at things so moving
forward you can also look at them in a
different way one way I like to look at
foods is in 3d nutrient space and so
here if you see this is a la fat along
this x
routine along this axis and then
carbohydrates along this axis you can
see where the different foods live in
that area so you can see candy bars are
way over here on the pastas are way over
here and most everything else is kind of
low on this end because they're kind of
low on on protein so moving forward we
can look at another way to look at foods
is labeling terms and so this gets into
a little more a few more the category
categorization type properties that we
have almonds so we have enemy types or
on fat labels and words like that so
these are kind of like new marketing
labels if you want to think of it that
way so here's just a couple of groups
together we can find all the foods that
are attached to each label and it's up
that you can kind of see for example for
long fat it looks like mostly in the
opening few of these on it's a lot of
non fat yogurts for example going a
little further I have some code here
where we can use box whisker chart to be
able to take that information and show
it all together in a meaningful way so
in this case I'm looking at just the fat
legal terms in terms of calorie content
and so you kind of see how the higher
fat terms are actually have more
calories to them compared to the lower
fat versions which is kind of
interesting and I have a similar thing
for you know sugar label in terms so you
can see sweetened as much as further to
the right on average then say no sugar
added in similar terms that way and
another way to look at them is in 2d
nutrient space Bob with a little extra
information here I'm using a bubble
chart to be able to include the size as
as well and the where the size of the
bubbles are however any foods match them
so you can see the most common ones are
terms like reduced fat and non fat for
example oh we can kind of see that they
they spread around a lot in the in fast
pace and not quite so much in in sugar
space it seems sweet and being the most
which is perhaps not surprising
moving forward some other information
that we have includes ingredient
substitutions we have a lot of curated
detailed information
about ingredient substitutions so for
example for allspice here you can see
this returns on association where the
left-hand side or the key is an amount
of a food and the right-hand side is a
list of entity groups which are possible
substitutions so for example allspice
can be replaced with ground cinnamon and
ground cloves and hand ground nutmeg for
example in different proportions Allah
now that might be a little difficult to
see because it's a little messy with how
much information is there so one way to
make it look a little better is to
leverage some of the other information
we have in the language including Allah
images so I have an opossum code there
where you can see where the left hand
side is shown now in a nice way and the
right hand side is grouped together to
see that what the actual foods would
look like in with those amounts so it's
a nice way to kind of them see things
there so we have ingredient
substitutions for explicit amounts you
may go awhile five milliliters it's kind
of a strange unit to use and the reason
for that is that we use on ma SI units
as best as we can um for those sorts of
things but we also do things in terms of
ratios so in this case there is no
amount in the left hand side and the
amounts on the right hand side of the
replacement are all in terms of percents
or counts for example and so this is I
am volume the percents on so you can see
that about 40% volume for these first
tube and about 6 percent by volume and
the nice thing about this is that if you
haven't changed if you have a different
amount of allspice you can replace it
with these just by multiplying using our
quantity framework and of course if you
want to go further yet we can look
further at more qualitative type
substitutions so you can see that a ma
substitutions can occur on say a food
type level so you can see that the
broccoli and apple have a few different
kinds of food types that they may go to
and one might be able to think a little
more about how to organize this or
visualize this on my into a network and
so it's not too hard to do that I will
go to the
like here where I've done this and in
the example there's the code and it's
actually in the notebook as well but I
won't show it here but this is a nice
way to sort of group on substitutions
according to their on the groups their
food type groups unlike sauces for
example and so the arrows sort of
indicate are the relations between which
substitutions occur online so you can
kind of see them most of the time groups
stick together for the most part which
is kind of interesting and lastly I'll
move forward a little bit into the
column ah talking about food groups for
my last example here and so one of the
one of the food group types we have is
called a basic food group which aligns
to the USDA my plate for example so here
I'm just going to import this image here
which if you're not familiar with USDA
is my plate they have this logo that
kind of indicates the relative amounts
of what you should have every day online
in terms of these basic food groups of
fruits greens vegetables protein and
dairy and with that information you can
use our entities for that and align them
to the colors that the USDA wants to use
for this logo for example so I just
looked up in their style guide what the
actual colors are and they define them
in terms of HTML colors which RGB color
now supports as a shorthand to be able
to get those out and so you can see when
they evaluate they evaluate to the
actual RGB colors in the language and
from here I won't be able to go into too
much detail on this but this couldn't
hear more or less grabs on all of the
food types for each basic food group and
then counts up how many there are in
each and we'll use that later another
thing that we can do is look at that
image and the original image we can
actually use the new and 12 color detect
and colors near to be able to for a
given color find where those colors are
and you can kind of see the results here
I'll pick out the individual areas on
that image which is really nice so these
are kind of like masks if you want to
think that way and the nice thing is is
that you can pass this to
on word cloud which takes as a second
argument a mask so that it will say make
the bird cloud in this area or to
exclude a certain area for example and
what we're going to do is set the color
function to be the color for the food
group that we figured out earlier and
use the image size option to be the same
size as the original image it's that way
it will kind of line up in terms of that
stuff and then you can multiply the
images together so that they will all
sit on top of each other without
colliding hopefully and the result
actually looks pretty similar to the
original and so this shows that shows
what the most common food types are in
each group on while still maintaining
the same shape and spirit of the
original
logo and so that's kind of a neat
example to show there and I think at
that point at this point I think I will
turn it over to Alan who I think will be
talking about historical and cultural
entities I'm Alan Joyce I'm the director
of content development for Wolfram Alpha
my team is focused largely largely on
domains that are outside of math and
science geographic historical cultural
data about the real world and it's
representation in the Wolfram language
and the Wolfram knowledge base so with
version 12 as over the past few versions
there have been steady incremental
changes and expansions across a lot of
the domains that are exposed as entity
types in the language new entities new
properties data updates improved
connections between entities and
different types that enable more
interesting computations one of the more
significant developments is just that
all of our several hundred entity types
are now fully documented for the first
time so if you go into the documentation
Center for the Wolfram language this is
the first time where any of these entity
types you can see examples you can get a
better sense of the scope and the
capabilities would give an entity type
and lots of examples for each type so
today I'm going to be focused on a few
examples from domains under the
and abroad umbrella of culture and
history so we've got some examples here
from covering historical events and
sights historical countries and military
conflicts both of which have had a
significant amount of work and expansion
in version 12 some things from kind of
culture and media we've got information
about lots of different media types I've
got some examples to go through just
showing how to work with data about
books artworks also about movies another
thing very popular that we've we've done
a lot of expansion on is coverage of
notable people across history and across
cultures and different occupations so
some information looking at how you can
explore genealogical connections looking
at relative popularity of people making
use of some of the alignment we've done
between canonical entities in the
Wolfram language and sources like
Wikipedia and also looking at some other
data related people like given name
popularity over time and finally just
some more broad kind of language and
culture topics looking at data about
mythological figures which is kind of
interesting and also looking at how you
can explore and visualize data about
languages alphabets and writing scripts
so just jumping in here one of the
things that we've really made some
effort to do is aligning entities
between types so for example you know a
given historical site entity is going to
have properties where the values of
those properties are other entities in
the language so you can build up graphs
of relationships between entities the
same type of different types you can use
these to do interesting lookups and
filtering of of entity classes so you
know you can do things here like take an
entity class of historical sites where
the the subjects that are commemorated
include FDR and with that generate a geo
this plot look at labels so this is
found a handful of historical sites that
are associated with FDR a lot of Beddoes
on a map the same thing with historical
events there are you know many thousands
of significant historical events in the
language we can
find things where one of the people
involved is Anne Frank and then use this
nice timeline plot functionality to look
at all those historical event entities
on on a timeline historical countries
this is something we really have put a
lot of work into getting not only the
countries themselves represented but
also having polygons for those countries
throughout their history so showing the
extents of different countries empires
civilizations and being able to pull
those into different kinds of
computations so say the Roman Empire you
can grab a list of properties here let's
say the rough start and end dates and a
polygon now the default polygons for
historical country is kind of the
largest polygon in the series that we
have the maximum extent of that country
or civilization not the union of all the
all the area that has ever covered but a
period of time where it was at it was at
its largest but then you can specify
using dated wrapped around that polygon
property you can pick a polygon for a
specific point in time and then it's
just as simple as putting that inside of
Geographics and you get a map for the
Roman Empire in the year 0 those
polygons can also be used in other kinds
of computations just applying geo area
to any arbitrary polygon you can get a
rough sense of the total size and that
polygon we can also map geo area over a
list of all the polygons we have
available for a country looking at the
ebb and flow and the size and splits and
schisms and in those countries and being
able to plot the changes in size and and
land area over time we can also take a
look at doing lookups here so here for
example we're looking at historical
countries we want to find the ten
largest countries in a given year and
then apply Geo area to those polygons
and you know here we get a list of those
countries
and then we can take all of those and we
can generate a map that shows all those
countries in their extents in the world
at that time military conflicts is
another interesting and very messy
domain but this is something where we're
we're engaged in a lot of ongoing
curation trying to expand coverage of
events and also the kind of data that's
available so for military conflicts
there's a huge range of possible
properties here we have you know for a
given conflict of any size you can look
at sub conflicts going down to campaigns
and battles and different kinds of
skirmishes looking at commanders on
different sides or in the different
factions involvement conflicts looking
at forces looking at casualties you know
depending on the data that's available
for the conflict this can go down to
specific kinds of troops and armaments
and you know casualties and destruction
of war materiel of different types but
again digging in here we can look at say
the list of battles under a particular
conflict you know there's 37 here
distinct entities that are connected to
the Second Punic War when you're looking
at data for military conflicts what you
get back here is a list where all the
data for given properties return on a
list corresponding to the list of
primary combatants in that campaign or
in that conflict so this is the Roman
Republic and Carthage and then whenever
you get values for that you've got those
values in the same sequence that those
actors are listed here I won't explain
the code but this will be available in
the notebooks that are shared but you
know with this data you can do some
interesting things like looking at all
of those conflicts in a given war and
starting to accumulate casualties over
time and getting a sense of how that
overall campaign may have flowed how
well each side was affected we can look
at casualties we can look at troop sizes
used in each battle over time
and then we can do things like you know
look at changes in corresponding this
with military conflicts and the actual
historical country is involved looking
at changes in territory over time and
seeing where there's some key inflection
point in the course of that war where
one side gained much more territory in
the other side suffered some serious
losses moving on from history again we
have lots of different entity types
covering different types of media books
music works albums music acts movies
periodicals lots of different kind of
data available for each of them
something I don't think Andrew had
mentioned but yeah and I've seen some
people asking how to get all the
properties of an entity on the chat here
but one of the simplest things given an
entity or maybe you've done this by
typing in control equals and then typing
the name of the entity just asking for a
data set of values will give you all of
the properties that are available for
that entity and all of its property
values similarly you can do something
like Association nope and give me one
second because I think I've just had a
had a crash while I'm loading that up
again I'll just note that this is a page
in the in reference for the Wolfram
language there's a page that has a list
of all the available entity types and
these are grouped by different kinds of
categories one second and this is a nice
way to explore as I said some of the
syntax for calling different aspects of
those entities seeing some specific
examples associated with each of those
entities
alright let's return to this I am just
going to expand this and we will work
finished working through this notebook
here just to get things moving again
books one thing looking at a data set of
property values we can do some things
here like constructing an entity and
bliss identity class taking it's an
entity class of books that were
published in some particular date
interval
everything in the 19th century for
example you know there are 341 books
that we've got represented as entities
and then you can do something
interesting here like take some of those
books in generator generate a word cloud
where the author's names are weighted by
the number of books in that class we
happen to have a lot of works by Jules
burn which may have something to do with
our scientific bent and the company but
there's a lot of information here
including four works that are in the
public domain
often the full-text of books which opens
up some other kinds of analysis you can
do moving on and looking at other kinds
of art artworks lots of different
properties of artworks you know
everything from creators and dates of
creation to physical measurements
weights Heights widths diagonal
measurements aspect ratios so we can do
some things say look up artworks by a
particular artist get a list of all
those artworks we could look at artworks
completed in a particular year and find
those that we have some images for you
can also start combining some of these
things so for example constructing an
entity class of artworks by a particular
artist Jeff Koons and then let's take
the 30 tallest artworks and get a list
of those and then you can do things like
for some of them we actually have geo
positions with their permanent
installations and we know where they're
located in the world you can look at
those on a map for others we have images
and you could do something like make an
image collage where the size of the
images are weighted by the relative
height of those works again movie data
I'm gonna move a little quickly here so
since we got delayed by having a crash
but we've got information on movies you
can pull up specific properties of a
specific movie again you can do an
entity class here where we're saying you
know give me the the ten top box office
grosses in 1980 and you get
list of those movies and again you can
do things like just to get a quick sense
of their relative box office do an image
collage where they're weighted by that
property value people there are several
hundred thousand notable people
represented representatives entities
across all time periods and countries
and occupations as I mentioned one of
the things we've been making more of an
effort to do is establish connection
between people
so certainly family relations are
important parents spouses children
represented as other types of entities
and when you have that it's possible to
do some interesting things like using
the nest graph function and start
walking down through all these relations
and you know construct a graph of the
children of a particular person going
down several levels and you get a nice
little slice of the royal family treat
here as I mentioned we've got
connections between entities in the
language and links to external sources
like Wikipedia wiki data so you can use
the Wikipedia data function which is
very handy and I believe in version 11
we added a property to get the daily
page hits for a given page in Wikipedia
so using that as sort of a proxy for
general popularity of an entity look at
Wikipedia data to get page hits for John
Lennon plot that over time you see some
cycles which may be tied to you know
people's birth death they tend to come
up in the news other events that show up
we can again look at music acts with
particular members we can use Wikipedia
to find and plot the relative popularity
of those bands which this should
surprise nobody I think I'll use Wings
fans out there or again just with
specific people you know find all the
members of a given music act and then
apply Wikipedia data across those people
and look at their relative popularity in
Wikipedia given named data also
interesting there are 116 thousand plus
given names that we have detailed
historical data on from the Social
Security Administration so you can look
at things like you know the fraction of
all births and other registration
giving year that were accounted for by a
particular name John you very very very
popular steadily declining over the
years although if you look at the the
overall rank you can see even though the
fraction may have decline you know john
was a plus percent of all registrations
in late 1800s down to less than one
percent in the twenty-first century
the rank is still relatively high we've
gone from one down to twenty five twenty
seven maybe four john there's a bunch of
other interesting things you can do when
you combine these with other entity
types let's say mark the release date of
breakfast at tiffany's and look at
whether there was a surge in popularity
of the name tiffany after that date it's
kind of an interesting point there Game
of Thrones has surprisingly started to
make a showing in these data sets
recently for anybody who follows it I
guess maybe it shouldn't be surprising
at this point Aria has been among the
most popular having the stark children
at least and then just looking at the
most popular names in a given year you
know for the latest year it's easy to
pull out the the given names that it
cannot fit a large the top ten largest
fraction of male and female names and
plot those finally just a couple of
quick things going far back here we do
have data on mythological figures and a
lot of different mythological traditions
so again for a given figure this is what
I was trying to show before you can ask
for a property association and you get
all of the the properties available for
that entity and all of the values for
each of those properties you get a nice
view of all the data that's available in
the language that you can work with you
can again look at mythological figures
that are a particular type in a
particular culture say deities and Greek
mythology and get a list of those using
the filtered entity class functionality
that Tony and Andrew had mentioned
before create a function where you're
looking for other mythological figures
whose symbols intersects with the list
of symbols associated with the Zeus and
then taking a look at what
cultures those are from and what those
specific figures are from doing some
grouping by patron jizz looking at which
which entities which particular aspects
of life have the most deities associated
with them and doing some other
interesting things like take all of the
mythological figures associated with the
underworld graph them and their
relationships to other things that they
are the patrons of and finally languages
alphabets writing scripts this is a lot
of really really rich detailed data here
you can do things like analyze lexical
similarity of languages generate graphs
where you're getting start burrowing
down and looking at the connections
between languages and how closely
related they are and then things like
writing scripts and alphabets these are
important but there's subtle differences
here you know for Latin for example as
both are writing scripts and there is
also a Latin alphabet the properties
that are available for each are
different the alphabet is focused on the
actual characters the writing script is
more some of its ISO designations and
classifications different aspects like
is it left to rights
are there other kinds of things as
whitespace required between words and
all this stuff is represented in a way
that's computable and you can look up
related writing scripts in that way
and you can do things like find other
writing scripts that share certain
characteristics say everything with a
bottom base line left-to-right writing
direction that uses white space between
words get a list of all those writing
scripts similarly other alphabets that
make use of the latin script and just
start digging down and do some
interesting things like look at word
clouds of you know all the characters
weighted by the number of different
alphabets that they appear in in all of
the alphabets that use the Latin writing
script okay I am going to pass things
over to Kate go to and I apologize for
the glitch there but we will move on
with presentation Hey Thank You Alan my
name is Keiko Shima I'm a developer in
scientific content
were hunting biology and medicine data
and in this presentation I'm introducing
sets of biology and medical related data
collections accessible and warm language
and our goal is to make all biology
computable and we have been actively
expanding the warm knowledgebase in the
area of life science and our curated
data collections cover quite diverse
areas ranging from human and animal
Anatomy to animals and plant species to
diseases and genes and in this notebook
we are analyzing and visualizing data
using the building of language functions
and looking at some examples from each
entity domain that showcase key
characteristics or biological systems so
starting out by looking at anatomy areas
the anatomical structure entity domain
provides information about more than
90,000 human anatomical parts here are
some sample inputs entities anatomical
concepts like organs muscles bones and
body segments those are known entities
in the Wolfram language and for each
anatomical structure over 120 properties
available to access additional details
for example get information about scared
of skeletal connections over bone of
course you can use control echo and
enter freeform natural language query
for conversion to inline bottom language
input and evaluate it so you can get
muscle attachment adjacent joint
articulate articulating bones
information here and in addition to
textual data 3d graphics models are
available and we have models for over
6000 anatomical parts and this is
showing the hand and in addition to a
human anatomy now we have the new set of
animal anatomical structure data
available in the latest version 12 and
the most recent data sets include
comparable information about canine dog
and also horse anatomical structures and
like an illuminator for humans various
image and graphics properties available
the pointers for instance you can get
the typical morphology of a horse brain
or get the image of the dog's toe bones
viewed from different perspectives and
additionally you can make use of
percheron graphics functions to explore
internal structures of animal body in
this example you we use an automated 3d
function to visualize the joint over the
orc
as you can see meta information is baked
in the model and you see the associated
entities for each sub part of the
structure and you can also add some
custom stylings to this visualization
and here we can specify the tissue
colors in this case we use Anatomy
styling option and specify muscles to be
colored blue and here and additional
proteins are also available to customize
your visual
so top seems like x-ray vintage stars on
these are available as well and in the
next example we use the clip plane
options and fading to die not me plot 3d
function to selectively cut outer layer
masking and muscles to expose the
internal structure in the graphics like
this and with all these accessible tools
you can also visually compare the
anatomical parts of an animal with the
homologous which means evolutionary
preserved structures and in this example
we are comparing the feet skeleton in
x-ray style we are one of the largest
bones this calcaneus bones are
highlighted in a graphics and next one
this one involves bit more coding but we
can also color associated structures and
explore the homologous skeletal
structures across different organisms
and now coming back to human anatomy
another mediator itself was also
expanded since introduced in version 10
and now it includes MIDI to bring
anatomy information so let's take a
brief look at computational neuroscience
area our collection of 3 Anatomy models
not only includes brains large cortical
areas but also includes individual gyrus
structures and even smaller nuclei so
first looking at on this is the brains
large cortical area prefrontal cortex
beautiful
different perspectives
and each subpart of these prefrontal
cortex can be colored using an approach
3d function with proteins scientific
approach theme and also additional
properties available to help you
categorize brains associated function or
identify its hierarchical relationships
and not limited to individual brain
support you can also analyze the
component of an app north persuade and
here you get the components of a human
visual pathway and here the possible
components and we can feed those into
anatomy probe 3 again to visualize the
pathway in a graphics and you can also
see the smaller nuclei as well not
limited to the large parts of the brain
you can also explore the neuronal
network of the brain and here you find
new neural output of a particular brain
region by accessing this new neural
neuron or output property in anatomy
data and we can visualize the
connections using the nest graph
function here and this is network and
also built in mathematical graph
functionality help us analyze the
network further and this feedback loop
is one example it's the key framework in
any biological network to fine-tune
system and you can for example find a
specific circuit that in force for
example amygdala and prefrontal cortex
and the highlight in the grass and you
can also identify the optimal flow from
the year maga Amidala to the output
structure which in this case is a spinal
cord and also highlight in the network
graph and after looking at the
components of the brain let's explore
the functions variety of cognitive
process taking place in the brain can be
categorized and hierarchically mapped
and you can get basic information about
higher order brain activities and other
physiological functions of the human
body by accessing the properties of
anatomical functional concept entities
and you can get basic information like
its definition and hierarchical conserve
our concepts and standard experimental
tasks to assess those cognitive
cognition and in addition to this you
have an access to statistical maps of
brain activity which is based on
meta-analysis of fMRI studies and here
is a sliced image of the brain our
horizontal is sliced during the visual
face recognition processing and with a
very simple line of course you can also
create the collage also discovering
activity maps like this moving on to
topics on animals and plants we have a
comparable data on popular domestic
animals and for dog breeds
we have entities described over 300
types of popular brie priests
and you can compute a basic information
like height weight and country of origin
and typical temperaments for individual
type of dog breeds and you can do fun
things like sorting or dog breeds by
their height to compare or dog trees or
you can do create a word cloud based on
dog's temperament temperament and most
recently we also introduced data on
horse breeze and for over 240 types of
horse breeds you can get information
like types uses physical characteristics
information about a horse breed and you
can make use of implicitly defined
entity class function to selectively
find a group of horse breeds with
specific property values of your
interest sample fine horse breeds by
uses or find by their origin and another
cool thing that you can do is analyze
and visualize the relations
relationships of horse breeds based on
their ancestry information and find how
they are likely developed historically
and in addition to breeze data we also
have data own species taxonomy our
database contains taxonomic information
for 1 million organisms and you can
easily fill the taxonomic sequence
information this information to the
graph function and visualize
hierarchical organizations or species
tax taxa and in this example in the next
example we use the graph Union function
to combine the taxonomic graphs or to
separate
species and illustrate how they are
likely separated in the taxonomic series
and similarly plant energy domain
provides information about 170,000
plants and in addition to taxonomic
information you can access their plant
distribution information in North
America and use Geographics function to
highlight it on the map also implicit
redefine entity class function is useful
to selectively find plants that have
specific characteristics such as orange
flowers with mature hi to listen to feet
and find those plants and moving on to
other life science domains our disease
data set is recently updated to include
additional information about medical
conditions and the patient statistics
and this domain is closely related to
other biology and medical entities so
for instance you can look up icd-10 and
it is which stands for international
classification of disease cause
associated with medical condition or
find disease associated with certain
anatomical structure entities and you
can also compute statistical information
in this example we compute the trend of
diabetes prevalence in the world and you
get a time series data and that can be
fed into the database plot to see the
trend the other example here we get the
disease prevalence rate by countries and
map them
using the Geo region value plot and to
see it on the map Alice River from
knowledgebase provides gene sequence
data for humans as well as other model
organisms and this gene example is
created by another biology develop our
own castle and you can make use of
sequence alignment in our function to
compare homologous gene sequences and
here we take eme one gene as an example
you can find ya mean one gene homologs
for the selective organist lected
organisms in this case we selected mouse
rat chimpanzee and humans and retrieve
the reference sequences and then use the
sequence this is a sequence and then use
the sequence alignment function to
compare and just for demonstration
powers we just selected the beginning
sequence of the genes and this is the
aligned part in this misaligned part
this is bound alignment between
chimpanzee and human and mouse and rat
and you can kind of conform that gene
sequences for human and chimpanzees are
much more similar than those for rats
and mice so this concludes the topic on
biology and medical entities and we are
constantly expanding about contents to
help students lime learn biology so more
to come soon and we will be interested
to hear what additional topics or
functionality could be useful so thank
you very much thank you Keiko and yes as
we close today the survey for
will appear on your and a window in your
browser that will give you the
opportunity for everyone to put in any
suggestions ideas or kind of their wish
list for data areas and domains that
you'd like to see some expansion or
support for in the in the Wolfram
knowledge base thank you everyone for
all these questions that are coming in I
know and thanks to our crew here our
presenters and others who are behind the
scenes furiously responding to all these
questions as much as we can
Allen I wondered if I might ask you to
mic up again and respond to some of the
questions that we've seen that we've
seen a few of them that are you know
repeated by a lot of people I see it I
see this from one that I think you're
talking about is uh is it possible to
edit an existing database to add new
personalized fields that the one you're
talking about yeah we did have a
question like that I think probably this
is this is better handled by Tony or
Andrew because this is talking more
about sort of generalized entity
framework functionality
I guess extending built-in domains with
data from individual users like creating
new new way data so open that up to the
panel and if somebody wants to take ask
us to send them the share we can
certainly do that if you want to share
something
well I mean I guess one of the things
that somebody could do is take take a
given entity type and create their own
entity store with the data from that
entity type and then add or modify their
own properties does everybody have my
screen yep again in the in the Wolfram
language documentation Center there is
there is one big sprawling guide page
that has a list of all of the entity
types that are exposed in the language
and like I had mentioned before this is
you know a couple of brief references
here as people have noted if you want to
enter some natural language input and
specify specify an entity control equals
wearing that up you can construct your
own entity expressions with entity and
then a given property in brackets will
get a property of specific entity but
this is a this is the whole huge list of
all the different entity types so we've
got things from Geographic entities
astronomical transportation engineering
culture food and nutrition the list goes
on and on and on and as I had noted
before maybe we can take one of the food
types any one of these pages will have a
box that gives you kind of a an overview
of the syntax that you use to specify an
entity to get properties of those
entities get a list of properties
constructing doing lookups doing an
implicit identity class where you're
looking up all the you know for example
foods that have a given value or
specification for a given property these
pages will list some sample entities so
you can get a sense at a glance what are
what are the entities in this domain
actually like there will be property
lists that show you all the canonical
forms of the names of those properties
and a more readable description of them
for food this goes on almost forever
it's an impressive domain some
additional details these are some
general things that apply to all entity
types I've seen someone asked how do you
find out
what the provenance of the data is and
for specific entity properties you can
directly query in the language for a
source which will return an answer D
that represents the the primary sources
that were used for that property and
then again there are just lots of
examples for each of these entity types
and these are all if you if you're using
Mathematica if you're working in the
cloud whatever kind of we are using to
work in the Wolfram language any of
these inputs or just click to copy one
of these inputs paste it into your
notebook evaluate it and you can just
immediately start working with all these
things and these examples will generally
range from you know fairly simple
trivial examples of just working with
very basic things to some of the more
complicated kinds of lookups and
visualizations that we've covered here
today thanks Allan and we're just about
it at the end of time but it may be one
last reference for the data repository
as far as how that relates to sharing
and storing custom data sets sure one
second yeah I think we've there there
I'm sure there are a few switch screen
cats that we've got somewhere and well
from you talking about
kind of curating your own data and how
to submit things to the Wolfram data
repository but for anybody who you know
people who are interested in working
with creating their own entity stores or
taking some of the data that's built
into the language and extending that and
creating your own collections of entity
types and things this is one place where
you can you can find some additional
data sets here to work with these are
all categorized and again these are
things where you can go into a specific
data set these are things you can call
directly in the language and just start
working with some of these examples and
explore the data you also can you know
directly create your own sorry I'm
trying to pull up a window here you can
create your own
entity stores so if you're working in
Mathematica working language you can
create a new notebook and repository
item this will bring up a notebook that
lets you define your own data repository
item so you can fill in lots of metadata
you can put data into it you can submit
it to this data repository and it'll be
reviewed and shared with other people or
that notebook will also show you how to
just share it to your own private cloud
account and then you can share with
whoever you want it doesn't go through a
review process but it'll create a nice
shingle with examples that you can use
in you know whatever kind of field of
work you're in thanks Alan appreciate
that kind of a on-the-fly little summary
there and we're out of time but I again
I want to thank everyone for
participating today our next session
will be two weeks from today we'll be
covering mathematics and scientific
visualization topics everyone who's in
the webinar now will receive reminders
by email about that event we'll also be
sending you a link to our archive page
it's the same length that you've had
before and just to clarify some
confusion on that when you go to that
broadcast channel link that URL that we
send in the email you simply click on
the video there'll be one set of an
archive video from first webinar two
weeks ago there will be a second
archived video appearing soon for
today's sessions and if you click on
those individual videos you'll see a
download link appear in the area of the
video controls the screen and that's
your download link to the presentation
notebooks that are all zipped together
so and we've put out some links to that
here as well so you will be getting all
those by email also a reminder that
there are twitch stalks happening every
Tuesday and Thursday throughout these
summer months so check out the Wolfram
channel on twitch TV to see more from
directly from developers as they share
new functionality in version 12 and
please do give us your feedback on the
survey as that shows up on your screen
where we are going to shut the session
down now
I look forward to seeing you next time
and have a great rest of your day